democrats can run but they can't hide
from joe biden's half a trillion dollar
student debt free for all vulnerable
democrats in some tough midterm races
waking up to the reality that swing
voters might not be so kind to a party
that can't stop pouring gasoline onto
the inflation fire they're revolting
against biden's bailout with some sharp
rebukes calling it quote out of touch
and saying quote it sends the wrong
message and even the left-leaning
washington post is calling it a
regressive and expensive mistake
the white house responding to all of
that and dismissing concerns
this is about
getting people to vote ahead of the
midterms that the real national
emergency is democrats in the midterm
elections well i mean uh
i
disagree with everything that you just
laid out we have said we're not going to
make everybody happy
and so if you're not making everybody
happy
you cannot say that you know that what
you just laid out is certainly cannot be
the case either
but one delusional democrat is
downplaying all the warning signs and
giddy about their midterm prospects
how are you feeling about the chances of
the democrats holding on to the senate
is this the thing
i'm liking it i'm liking it i'm liking
it
but the biggest question mark is how
much will all have to pay for this new
estimates have the taxpayers on the hook
for as much as 600 billion dollars but
the white house refuses to tell us a
price tag
how much does this cost
you know the projections are still uh
coming out depending on how many people
uh take advantage of it but let me
remind folks what's the reason about
this secretary what's the what's the
range of possibilities
well like i said um those projections
are still coming out based on how many
people take advantage of it
okay so there you have it the president
handing out money based upon a pandemic
but every day he says the economy is
great every day they fight to say that
we're not in a recession every day they
say title 42 is no longer relevant and
we're not going to use it we're not even
buying vaccines anymore
so
on what basis does the president make a
decision that young
healthy
educated people with a long life and a
career ahead of them are entitled to
this kind of uh of remedy
talking to me yeah i am brian looking
right at you all right
uh i don't think he wanted to do it i
think he would have done it 18 months
ago if he wanted to do it the word
behind the scenes was the word that got
to him was this is a legacy builder
we're going to build a legacy so they
wheel in john meacham whoever michael
beschloss and they say how this will
help define you he knew that it's this
is unfair inherently reminds me a little
what harold ford was saying last night
that this ten thousand dollars the
impact it's going to make on the deficit
undo's what he said was necessary with
this other plan that came through also i
just i'm laughing at the fact that
they're pretending as if no democrats
are against this they keep saying
republicans right-wingers mitch
mcconnell excuse me tim ryan chris
pappas
mike bennett the senator uh jared
goldman uh a house member from maine uh
charisse davis from kansas cortez masto
i mean there was many high-profile
democrats who want nothing to do with
this and now fox is saying it's between
500 and 800 billion dollars
well and you know the interesting thing
about that jesse is you know whether
it's a half a trillion dollars or more
than a half a trillion dollars karine
jean-pierre insists upon saying well we
really don't know how much it's going to
cost how could they not know how much
it's going to cost are they that
reckless that they would put our
national debt even higher almost a
trillion dollars and say well we really
don't know well she doesn't know because
it's not in her binder and no one knows
and they don't care
and that's the truth she says that
experts
have told them that it's going to break
even now experts have not had a good
track record the last couple years nobel
laureate
yeah we're going to go back to that
when is a reporter going to say which
expert which expert says that who's she
going to trot out you're going to try it
out jill there are no experts these
people don't exist
and then biden is out there saying i
have the power to do this like he's
america's dad it's like all right sally
you know what let's call it even just be
nice to your mother for the rest of the
summer you can't do that i mean this is
the way maybe his family ran things if
you look at the history of the biden
family they were always getting
suspicious loans from donors a delaware
bank just happened to give him a
no-interest loan for a home
hunter pays the family bills you can't
run a country like this you're saying
that he's using
pandemic powers when are those over
answer never yeah they're running the
republic like he's a king and it's not
fair because the republican gets into
the presidency and they run it like a
president
but you can't compete against the king
when the congress and the press let him
be a king
usually you have the middle class that's
defined as like fifty thousand to a
hundred thousand now
trump beat crooked among those middle
class voters biden eked out a victory
among the middle class last time but now
he's betrayed them you can't just
bail out
grad students making six figures on the
backs of middle class people you can't
raid the treasury to just pay bribes to
the upper class you can't do it now he
used to have a little more class
consciousness that was scranton joe
he's maybe too old maybe he got rolled
by the radical left because they have
debt but even as you said these
democrats in competitive races
they know it's a wedge issue and he's on
the wrong side of it you know dana i'm
going to ask you a question that you
asked yesterday and that is um is it
legal i mean a year ago joe biden nancy
pelosi said it wasn't congress has the
power of the purse does the does the
higher education act give them the
ability to negate this and and i'm going
to say one more thing jason furman
suggests it's going to cost the average
taxpayer two thousand dollars
at least right because this i i think
that it could be higher than 500 billion
because it depends on the income
thresholds and i also think this is not
the only time they will do this and that
is why i'm hoping that somebody does
bring a lawsuit and that they can have
standing i read this whole long article
day about standing standing means
basically that you have the right to sue
so but the way the higher education act
reads it's almost like wait what do you
mean that none of us would have the
right to sue now another thing on the
pandemic loans for example those were
passed by congress that was a discussion
that was had in congress they put their
names on to the vote and they said fine
we're going to do this this is joe biden
saying i'm just doing this with my pen
and on the legal front i think it's very
interesting that they had to lean on the
911 authority to get this done now that
was for military
and they're having to go all the way
back there that means that it's called
the hero act let me tell you something
aoc not a hero in this
okay and i i was thinking today about
how i would love to interview her i'm
sure she would never come on but
i know somebody who lives in wyoming who
is around her same age bought a backhoe
this is a heavy piece of equipment and
it's used um for work around their
property and also they do work for
others they get hired to do some work
pays a lot of bills it's really great
they take out a loan to buy the backhoe
why is she more deserving
of loan forgiveness than he is i would
love to ask her that and i and
not and hopefully she would have an
answer my last point i would like to
make is just about the white house
answers on this
there's nothing in the binder nothing
they can't answer who will pay for it
who has the authority
they try to say that oh well by the end
of the year it's going to be a wash
that's not true that's just actually
there's no such thing as a free lunch we
all know that the money has to come from
somewhere and it's coming from you
harold
so i shared my views about this
yesterday and and
i think that you look at this in two
ways fairness and inflation the fairness
issue i think we've talked about around
the table today and we talked about it
yesterday and other shows all across the
network you if you paid off all your
debt a year ago yep um why is it and you
saved and your family saved and you made
sacrifices
it's unfair to that it's unfair that
family even a month ago for that matter
several years ago
um so i think democrats we're going to
have to explain that a bit again i think
all of this should have been conditioned
on
providing uh help for
those who are going into professions
that we need more of pilots teachers
family doctors nurses truck drivers
engineers we could go down the list but
we are jesse you made the point
yesterday about some majors and i got
criticized by a family member of mine
who's an art history major for talking
about art history
that being said we still if we're going
to shell out these kinds of dollars and
it's 300 billion i made the point
yesterday to your point brian we negated
what we the 300 billion that joe manchin
negotiated in the inflation reduction
act so it concerns me now the white
house will argue that you give these
kids an opportunities young people an
opportunity of 43 million americans
borrowers who are affected by this 20
million that 43 have their that they're
forgiven all together so will they be
able to invest more in their own
businesses invest more in their
communities buy a home invest in their
kids education i would hope so that
would be their argument finally the
inflation piece jason furman and summers
and others have all talked about this i
get i i think some people need to take a
little of the sanctimony out of this
i've heard some of my republican friends
and their old friends in the congress
being really critical of this i would
remind all of us that when we passed the
ppp loans members of congress their
businesses got forgivable loans under
the law
and that was two trillion dollars and
we're now saying that inflation was
caused by some of these things you can't
be against inflation when it helps you
politically one day and not be critical
don't you think it's a little bit
different one is an elective i chose to
go to college a pandemic thanks to china
destroyed the
country brought this to his knees so i
had no choice we're talking about the
i'm talking about inflation the
inflationary pressures i'm not i don't
but i think people should not the
sanctimony needs to be removed from it
there's members of congress whose
businesses got millions of dollars and
like a lot of americans those loans were
forgiven you can't say inflation this is
going to pour and worsen inflation which
i think it will i'm just not going to be
on a high horse about it but at the same
time you didn't have to take the money
you could have said you know what this
is going to lead inflate lead to
inflation so i'm not going to take the
millions of dollars i think you're
eating apples and oranges at the same
time not on the inflation argument i
don't i don't think so but whatever the
case this bill here what this president
has signed on on this i just hope people
everybody needs to take a step back the
white house if you think this is the
right thing to do you're going to have
to have an answer on where this money
comes from you can't say you don't know
what the writing said cut the interest
rate some of these interest loans on the
student loans are ten percent right how
do they really get away with that if you
want to go up to everyone says hey if
you're paying five percent i'm gonna for
for the next year 18 months you're
paying two percent to me that it makes
more sense brian i totally agree and at
least you can understand what it costs
you're understanding also congress
should do it you can't just have the
king do it we don't work that way well
pelosi said that he could not do this
pelosi's quoted a year ago
but you
know but the other thing is it's part of
an institutional thing that they're
doing the colleges are raising the money
while they're giving them money and it's
not level with inflation it's it's part
it's a whole you know it's like an
enterprise and organizers
why not pair this also with bringing
these these these university heads
before it's explaining me why tuition
costs have jumped way past inflation
what are these kids getting for this
huge gap you know what they're getting
not much uh and we should the the
federal government are not getting much
history majors kids are if you look at
you look at the jungle
a friend of mine has a kid who has a
business with tools and a truck he goes
out he has to buy the tools first he's
not getting any kind of a break this is
he who doesn't make any money uh if he
doesn't sell his tools you know what
it's not there it's not there it's just
not fair and that's the end of it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else